[Music]  Janice Dickinson is officially a married  woman to the 61 year old supermodel tied  the knot with her fiance dr. Robert  Gerner aka rocky on Saturday exchanging  nuptials in an intimate ceremony in  Beverly Hills California surrounded by  close friends and family I think the  thing that works about rocky and I his  family ahead of her big day Janice took  et wedding-dress shopping where she said  yes to a jane book gown I think this is  the dress Janice and rocky got engaged  in 2012 but put their wedding planning  on hold when she was diagnosed with  breast cancer in March we both  experienced taking care of each other  and kind of life-threatening situations  the product much more closely together  but it seems the pair was a perfect  match after being set up by rocky Sun  honestly I fell in love with rocky you  know on the blind date  you